d'ailleurs même bonsoir bonsoir
alors tu as dit en france on m'appelle
l'horrible allemand et en allemagne
celui qui est parti alors j'aimerais
avoir tout en doute quand même cette
semaine
tes réactions sur la victoire de la
droite en rda
quant à adil depuis que j'en avais dit
que les allemands de l'est avaient voté
avec leurs ventres c'est très facile
quand on va tous les autres celui de
dire des choses pareilles je faisais
pourtant quand même il avait pas manger
très très très bien depuis très
longtemps
il n'y a pas que le ventre parce que
leur système économique était calé 0,1
tout ce qui a été là pendant 40 ans et
plus c'était nul déjà du temps des nazis
l'industrie s'était pas tellement génial
dans cette partie le dernier parce que
c'était jamais il a vraiment l'art et la
chose industriel l'industrie cfai henri
lévy qui est polonais maintenant et
l'autre par exemple je prenais beaucoup
d'industriels allemands à qui on propose
des usines alors ses usines dans la main
des lettres ne valent pas un clou
fédérer une vidéo où tout est à
reconstruire
malheureusement c'est encore l'argent
qui reconstruit ce n'est pas lady du
logis est ce que tu crois que les
français ont eu tort ou raison d'avoir
peur de la réunification de l'allemagne
nous non c'est au contraire pour un
certain temps je parle même plus bas
économiquement affaiblir la nana la
marque donc arrangé fait aussi les
affaires des autres
je pense que dans cette affaire tout le
monde s'y retrouvera tout le monde fera
des affaires tout le monde
trouvera un nouveau marché et puis vous
avez l'allemagne ça n'est plus
l'allemagne débutants de la presse dit
l'allemagne étaient appelés pour venir
cela vous revient nulle part en europe
c'est avec cette absurde une ovation
alors je n'ai pas avoir réussi par sa
famille est originaire de hambourg
mais mon père je suis dehors points ils
ont traversé comment ta famille la
deuxième guerre mondiale je deviens j'ai
eu de la chance parce qu'ils mangent
états unis en 1938 je m'en souviens très
bien de la guerre c'est comme s'il
n'avait pas eu lieu parce que mon père
avait eu la bonne idée pour une autorité
différents d'acheter une propriété la
frontière danoise
juste avant la guerre et que j'ai passé
mon enfance et premier donné demain midi
dans ses propriétés à la frontière
danoise où s'est rien passé mon départ
ont été très riches tout en question wii
party c'est quand même propriétaire
entre le trèfle et que l'argent n'est
pas tout et puis ça fait pas le bonheur
comme on dit ça peut lui dit mais je
pense que de faire confiance à ces
enfants qu'on puisse faire est ce qu'on
a envie de faire
même si ça correspond vraiment aux
parodies des de tes parents c'est le
plus grand de ce monde l'aura 14 ans qui
est venu à paris pour pour faire les
études habiter à l'hôtel d'ailleurs non
une à un truc pour étudiants où tu vas
être vous était très bien je trouve ça
génial parce que c'est incroyable
quelquefois je regarde deux enfants
étaient 14 15 ans et je me dis comment
je faisais moi pour lui de tout seul
comme un truc alors à saison je fais un
concours organisé par le comité
international de la laine et tu as fait
un petit manteau en chevio john
incroyablement remy emma ah oui
la préhistoire oui mais c'est l'histoire
de l'année la vente illégale
oui c'est une chose d'un croc la gagner
le concours enfin ex-aequo avec saint
laurent lui avait une robe entre nous
j'étais jaloux de saint-laurent quand il
était star 20 ans avant de pouvoir
c'est un sentiment que j'ignore et je ne
fais rien par rapport aux autres jeunes
étaient les choses que par rapport à moi
il ya une styliste anglaise que je vais
prendre ce que j'aime beaucoup qui m'a
dit un jour n'est pas concernées va
confie il a un vice dans la ville est ce
que tu es sensibles critiques quand on
dit par exemple car c'est un excellent
metteur en scène mais c'est pas un
novateur ou des choses comme ça je te
salue tout de suite à l'hémorragie
d'adhérents qui n'a jamais les critiques
yapi tout cinq personnes dans le monde
dont le critique mais tous ces nazes
opinion alors ta carrière j'ai été
assistant d'abord chez balmain ou bien
renoncer à ses traders a ensuite été
directeur artistique chez patou une
styliste chez chloé dernièrement bien
sûr sauveur de chanel tout le monde le
sait sauf leur sauveur sauveur de il
faut pas non plus oublier oui mais enfin
je veux dire ça a été aussi sauvé si
tout a été en danger parce que le propre
de chanel à milady derrière ce qu'il
fallait
parce qu on ne sauve pas uniquement en
prêt dans la liste en disant voilà on a
pris ce styliste et maintenant ça va
marcher tout seul quand tu dessines
combien de modèles par an à peu près ça
ne plante jamais ce que je fais pas tu
fais le plein de modèles disent on est
là au moins on parle de 1700 parents
quand même est-ce que ça plus à fond
c'est aussi tout ce qui va à la poubelle
ouais est-ce que je n'utilise pas et
puis entre les collégiens allemands mes
collections italiennes et tout le reste
ça doit faire beaucoup plus donc je ne
compte pas pour moi
dessiner essayez travailler dans ce
métier s'est dévoué
une chose naturelle comme lecture et
soeurs car il ya les parfums en plus et
les accessoires et tu as dit un jour
cardin maintenant c'est devenu un
marchand de soupe est ce que t'as pas
peur à force de faire plein de licences
comme ça de chez moi un peu comme il ya
plein de licences comme ça je n'ai pas
envie d'avoir un restaurant puisque les
temps ni dans alimentaire dans
l'alimentaire j'ai pas envie d'y
retourner
alors ça n'a pas empêché donc évidemment
de connaître une réussite exceptionnelle
tu es riche et célèbre
alors on va commencer par la richesse
jacques combien de maisons aujourd'hui
ou d'appartement je sais pas moi comme
je suis un décorateur frustré sache pas
combien tu dessines de modèles je veux
bien croire mais les maisons qu'il vient
de se voir ôter mali la turquie dans ce
chantier qui dynamita appartement à
paris
il faut bien de levier des moments
restent d'habiter à l'hôtel je n'étais
pas d'électricité que tout est allé de
travers la pression pièce là bas qu une
pièce ou une pièce à rome tu as d'un
grand atelier d'un quartier où il y
avait beaucoup d'ateliers de peintre
danois au 19e siècle et a appartenu à la
était de l'atelier de doivent à un
moment donné à new york l'un des
facteurs mais ça j'y vais jamais j'ai
pas beaucoup de burqa ont beau faire
quelque chose en bougie maison sublime
qui est d'ailleurs j'ai donné à la ville
elle avec ma vie elle est la vie parce
que c'est un monument historique très
très très bizarre qui n'est pas fait
pour un usage familial à grandchamp son
manoir landrethun vérité mais j'y vais
jamais l'année dernière j'étais je crois
48 heures mais pour moi c'est pas
nécessaire d'habiter de l'endroit
l'essentiel cela existe à ma tête me dis
que je peux en faire et c'est un
chantier qu'il habite à bouger j'ai tout
l'arraché à l'intérieur et pas encore eu
le temps de refaire on s'est presque
inhabitables je peux même pas y toucher
pas qu'il ya une pièce avec ses 25
mètres de long fait rempli de livres
c'est vrai ça oui mais ça sedan
à monaco tu as quoi alors tu as beaucoup
déposée par hasard plusieurs choses de
cette fameuse villa qui resterait qui
est in a occupé pendant les visites et
la vigie qui connaît d'ailleurs
et puis j'ai aussi un appartement que
quand je vais avec moins de monde que je
vais tout seul à côté du palais qui est
dans une maison ancienne refaite cécila
quitterie 700 m² au 21ème étage ne s'est
pas suicidé l'échangé il est moindre en
suis fière mais il a plus de charme
parce que jamais mieux le syndicat
business avec arrêt sur une tour il
était amusant il vient même fif
mais c'était dans une maison nouvelle
évidemment jamais habité dans la maison
près de la maison cirque amar c'est ça
mais ça dépend directement de la maison
de retraite avec l'ascenseur pour la bm
je vais plus jamais vous que je me sois
dedans ce dernier devient trop lourd
pour tout perdu 15 kilos peut être
devrait on peut pas manquer en six mois
on la retire mais pas les deux tu as dit
aucune des sociétés pour lesquelles je
travaille ne m'appartient c'est ça ton
si c'était un flamand sur le visage des
royalties exactement par des
pourcentages votre canapé les flèches
fille mais je ne veux jamais être
concerné par tout ce qui est gestion à
faire je veux garder un sentiment de
liberté totale et que tout ce que je
fais je le fais parce que je veux bien
mais parce que tu es obligé de le faire
et pour moi c'est très important
alors tu arrives tu es célèbre c'est à
dire que y'a des gens enfin l'ailier des
sondages qui ont été faits tire quand on
le voit avec en catogan en éventail et
tes lunettes et par les partenaires mais
on dit on sait pas très bien ce qui fait
mon sexe et karl lagerfeld mais ça c'est
une bonne chose
oui c'est très bien
imposer une image médiatique oui très
fort à une chose qui a été moins
médiatiques ont vraiment parlé cinq
minutes c'est la sphère inès de la
fressange que la tienne enfin tu disais
en 87 c'est un peu ma fille si j'ai
signé avec chanel c'est aussi parce que
elle est là c'est la française il ya
l'un de ces problèmes c'est malheureux
ce qu'est et n'a jamais pu s'imposer à
l'étranger en allemagne en amérique qui
sont des marchés importants personnel
sur l'impact était nul parce que tu
disais c'est la française idéal puis le
jour elle été choisie comme la française
idéal c'est à dire pour incarner
marianne ce qui effectivement et c'est
là tu t'énerves étaient line renaud
c'est bourgeois s'est d'ailleurs zenny
bourgeois ni vulgaire c'était au fait
rien pour dire gentiment à quelqu'un
puisqu'après mathématiques ce que je
voulais l'aider à produire de plus en
plus dur ça que didier rey non content
et je pense que le temps pour être
mannequin s'est passé parce que tu dis
qu'elle était bourgeoisement fins appel
quand même 2 la fressange était une
taupe elle plafonne lagerfeld il n'y a
pas de titre en suède l'aria pas
défendre ton père était baron wipitta
général c'est héréditaire mais avec
kaiser quand même mais ça je ne suis pas
contre c'est pas moi qui m'appelle comme
ça c'est fairchild donc je ne peux rien
tu penses que c'était mauvais pour
chanel qu'elle se finance dans sa salle
de bain
son côté gauche mais maintenant elle est
complètement professionnelle n'existe
plus le visuel maintenance et les années
90 et c'est fini maintenant c'est
l'oligarchie faire c'est autre chose
puisque l'audience cela n'aura jamais un
contrat comme elle a eu la sq ni pour
claudia c'est bien ni professionnelle
parce que je pense que finalement les
machos pas qu'ils attachent une fille
cas que treize années 80 maintenant
c'est quelque chose maintenant
2 les gars je n'aiderai plus jamais un
mannequin de la même façon comme je les
ai aidés est ce parce que l'ingratitude
à ce degré a ses limites et à travers
tout jouer en vrai tu ne pas la
connaître
alors par contre est au mieux avec les
monaco a été très ami de la famille de
monaco
c'est vrai que tu corresponds
journellement avec le prince rainier
montrent ce fossé pas autre chose à
faire par contre quand on lis dans la
presse que tu trouves le prince albert
très spirituel c'est oui c'est vrai je
la connais il est très drôle à bord donc
ça tu confirmes pas français très
amusant
oui il a un grand nombre d'éducateurs et
d'acteurs qui est parti d'un micro nu
mais je trouve très très juste rien
alors tu as dit une phrase que je trouve
très très drôle dit dans le fond je m'en
sors pas mal parce qu'un bon âge pour
être pathétique parce que peuvent vous
mais je me pose pas trop de questions à
mon encontre sujet ouais tu veux qu'on
joue un jeu là ça dépend du jeu
[Musique]
cet été une injure
colère très violent comme ça qui
éclaterait la seule troupe qui durerait
longtemps quand même
je ne sais pas vraiment rancunier mais
j'ai beaucoup de patience c'était une
maladie oh
contagieux
[Musique]
c4est dit là ce qu'il fait très mal de
gros bourdon année c'est ça ce serait
qui pas dangereux
pourquoi parce que
j'aurais fait autre fait tous les deux
business avec les femmes pendant je sais
sur ma page et les exploitent une façon
pas sûr dit c'est clair si tu étais un
dictateur c'est un dictateur frédéric ii
de prusse tels que si c'était un vice
mais oui c'est pas une chose négative
si tu étais une bière dans mon métier
évidemment une guerre en dentelles
winship un poison
je serai un poison d'entre eux je suis
un poil
j'en mettrais thématiques que l'émission
karl lagerfeld qu'à regarder on a fait
tous les cas les avec carl lang mais on
n'a pas voulu aller à ces trois quarts
marx il est mort donc voilà on fait un
spécial car absolument alors karl
largerfeld ont offert une hyper view
vérité 1 alors l'hyper view c'est déjà
quelque chose du tout ces gens là vont
vous poser des questions
l'hyper yeux vérité c'est que vous
engagez bien entendu à dire la vérité
comme marie laforêt vient de le faire a
dit toute la vérité voilà alors ce qu'on
peut dire déjà pour commencer c'est que
vous avez réussi beaucoup de choses mais
surtout à imposer une image c'est à dire
vous êtes un vous êtes un logotype vous
êtes une icône quoi quand on voit
qu'elle quand on voit des lunettes
noires un catogan et un éventail depuis
l'éventail non parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut larguer les accessoires
awel gênant vous avez abandonné
l'éventail c'est fini oui oui je l'avais
pris pour une raison qu'il avait
différentes et pas proférer l'image
ouais je ne fume pas oui mais pas dingue
de la fumée des autres c'était seul
moyen pour s'en débarrasser d'accord
mais j'en fus moi j'ai pas besoin
d'accords sick of allume-cigare on va
vous prêter un ventilo parce que les
cigares figure nous sommes j'aime moins
que les cigarettes bonbons tu peux y
aller jean pierre alors donc même
effectivement même si les gens savent
pas toujours très bien ce que vous
faites ils savent que vous êtes karl
lagerfeld voilà c'était une réussite
comme une autre à la chanteuse gênant
qu'autre chose aux emails un bon vous
faites là justement on va en parler car
exemple nous avons beaucoup beaucoup de
choses
alors là il ya un truc qui s'est passé
ce qu'il a fait dans toutes vos sociétés
dans toutes vos activités
il ya une qui s'appelait qu'à elle et
qui a fait que déposer son bilan au
khalifat xl à peu près pas du tout ça
faisait partie d'un groupe avec lequel
s'était associé groupe vendôme où et
avec qui je m'entendais pas du tout et
je voulais qu'une chose elle a demandé
barasse est et j'ai récupéré tout mon
nom je vais récupérer votre nom voilà
c'est ce que je voulais voilà ça c'est
en même temps tous mes autres sociétés
et puis je la verrais pas oui il en
virée pas vous societe vous toucher des
royalties mais il est monsieur qu'il a
géré il vient d'être remercié par
bandeau manoir et en semant donc ça
devrait être c'est génial que la société
s'est vendu donc la société cas elles
n'existent plus les
y'en a une nouvelle qui avait live
gallery qui témoigna lagarfeld gabriel
galerie à paris qui voit là la new york
et qui est nul à monaco
voilà alors ses 48 scène donc cédé que
vous avez fait ça avec andrée putman
vous les connaissez qu'andrée putman
on vient d'avoir une effectivement à new
york à berlin monaco voilà c'est tout
votre monde à vous ah oui mais il ya
personne qui me dit vous rendez vous
faire ça ça ça c'est une chose à moi
personnellement avec mes propres sous et
ça m'amuse beaucoup plus parce que en
même temps ça doit différent de mes gros
client c'est-à-dire chanel et fendi vrai
que je veux pas être concurrents de mes
clients oui ton j'ai fait autre chose
alors y ait de la mode on peut on aimer
et de la mode il ya des y ait des livres
des photos puisque vous êtes on en
parlera à vii devient formant par les
choses que je fais en italie pour fendi
rihanna jay l'article on va là aussi
puisque pour le moment il ya ce fameux
sac baguette de fendi que le sac les
plus vendus du monde donc on le vend là
aussi le sac baguette à de belles
baguette qu'est ce que c'est assez dire
ça qu'ils se mettraient près du sous le
bras et je vois quelqu'un l'a appelée
baguette un jour il est devenu le sac
baguette
voilà c'est la traditionnelle le plus
porté pour le mandat mais ça laissez
vous met pas ces annonces dans tout le
monde on peut pas passer c'est déjà
journée des listes d'attentes
d'ailleurs vous allez voir après
l'émission elle vous l'a foot sous le
bras donc non alors là vous êtes devenu
alors ce qui est incroyable c'est devenu
un photographe vous a vu les photos et
lead rays carl rapt dire que vous êtes
devenus ses chroniques sont pas passés
si regarder comment ça génère du moment
où j'ai commencé à faire des photos il
ya 13 ans vous allez voir c'est ça et
vous êtes devenu à un photographe
mais maintenant les journaux du monde
entier vous réclame pour faire des
photos de jeu pourrait arrêter la sphère
la mode même si je voulais oui ça vous
allez assez d'argent avec la photo pour
joe pas question faisait moi je ne
travaille plus pour gagner de l'argent
car quand vous essayez quand vous étiez
petit vous vouliez déjà être
portraitiste ou carrés qu'elle juridique
des cadres et supporter et déjà vous
saviez énormément quand vous étiez petit
déjà on vous a surnommé le kaiser de la
mode mais d'alcool pas tant j'étais plus
jeune j'avais déjà c'est déjà ce que ce
que vous vouliez faire vous étiez déjà
mais je n'ai jamais changé d'idée oui
alors vous êtes allemand je crois que je
crois tout le monde ici peut le
constater
karl lagerfeld et allemands je pense que
merci d'envoyer sa bague ou la rive
alors en 46 était là alors qu'à j'ai
quand même quelques influences
étrangères d'origine qui font que j'ai
pas oui c'est teri pa s'entraide on vous
dit vous êtes un nom mais en france vous
êtes aujourd'hui a expliqué prêt
téléspectateurs c'est parce qu'il avait
un petit peu de retard
oui mais c'est pas grave du tout je sais
qu'il sera en mai pourquoi vous vous
êtes pas encore excusez-nous d'abord
personne puisque vous étiez en train il
me l'avait allumé m'arrive à moi il vaut
qu'à en faire ce dont vous êtes quelque
jean pierre dit oui c'est vrai il n'a
pas dit pardon contraire quand je vais
arriver l'impression de déranger
alors on a juste attendu une demi-heure
en france vous êtes cas en france vous
êtes l'horrible allemand et en allemagne
vous êtes celui qui est parti donc vous
êtes le seul endroit où j'allais dire
oui je sais bien le seul endroit où je
me sens étranger c'est mon pays
oui c'est vrai vous aimez pas
l'allemagne tu peux même pas l'allemagne
mais comme j'ai presque jamais vécu en
allemagne que je suis ailleurs depuis
que j'ai 14 ans c'est assez particulier
pour moi parce que en fait je parle
parfaitement allemand
je comprends que trop tout ça mais en
même temps je n'ai pas l'impression de
faire partie de ça oui
alors que vous étiez enfant vous étiez
vous aviez une mentalité d'adultes à ces
jeunes à effet les enfants quand j'étais
en voilà et vous vous détestiez les
autres enfants que j'étais déjà assez
infernal pour vous étiez enfant parce
que c'est cliché à l'âge de 5 ans vous
exigez un valet et des boutons de
manchette
oui c'est quand même assez brouillon
comme mon père ah oui à 15 ans ouvrait
un baril et votre votre mère vous dit
votre père d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
vous dis ne soit jamais danseurs ou
prêtres pourquoi mais pas et ma mère de
tester ses deux métiers pour un homme ah
oui et s'il le fait que celui devenu
couturier s'est pas bien passé ce métier
m'a dit non c'est bien de faire ça ça
prouve t pas snob qu'il n'en ferait pas
un horrible métier comme ça à l'époque
ce mais qui n'avait pas très bonne
presse
depuis on a arrangé ça dans le
prêt-à-porter
maintenant premiers prix dont le premier
prix d'un concours concours
international de la laine avec un petit
manteau cheville aux jo à droite mais ça
fait toujours sourire le manteau a été
réalisée par balmain faisait de vue
l'assistante dalmat un donc succès
absolument assistant d'un couturier 96
17 ans c'est bien mais c'est pas le
succès le lien à l'époque c'est l'argent
qui va être assistant d'un couture lui
d'accord mais à l'époque c'était plus
regardées et vie il est passé lui aussi
emballé c'est un peu pareil pour vous
vous êtes pressé directement de facteurs
à acteurs comme une lettre à la lettre à
la poste
c'était très facile point j'admire
beaucoup les gens pour qui c'est
extrêmement facile c'est ça si la
fillette alors oui alors votre a gagné
ce concours donc vous hills alors en lui
il avait dessiné une robe et voit un
manteau ça vous a pas rendu jaloux que
saint laurent soit star 20 ans avant
vous non non pas du tout parce que moi
j'avais d'autres priorités que lui
n'avait pas lutter beaucoup plus
ambitieux que moi oui donc nos produits
tout cela n'a pas gêné du tout du tout
du tout du tout j'aimerais pas être à sa
place aujourd'hui
ah bon pourquoi pour d'autres types de
raison parce que c'est mon papa de lui
donc ce n'est pas évident à k way
voulait discret quand même oui c'est
bien celui ci toute façon c'est une
émission d'une discrétion totale tenues
sexy même un truc qui fait la réputation
de l'émission dim bien par en bas chez
ardisson parce que moi on posera pas de
question personnelle
vous êtes un beau serge que s'ouvre aux
airs comme ça un peu grand seigneur et à
travailler beaucoup vite
l'autre test cette notion de travailler
beaucoup et quand un mec qui fait pas de
différence entre vie privée et vie
professionnelle en fait il n'y en a pas
parce que je ne crois pas que ça existe
parce que si on peut faire des
séparations sa foi d'un côté à l'autre
vous prenez tout ce que m
est ce que pour une fois on peut être
tous d'accord sacha d'achat j'aime ces
moments on partage la même opportunité
travail en amateur tellement fort de
votre gueule un coffre se fout de ma
gueule je connais je sais ce que madame
de retrouver les chantiers mais tu vas
me fait dire toi tout mais craig
enfin on pourrait si le réveiller
jean-pierre oui mcdonald's je suis dans
une question j'aurais juste en une
parité tout ça c'est de l'humour ou quoi
c'est une attaque jean père parce que
j'essaie de vous réveiller
je vous et quel que soit reconnue plus
brillants nous ça mais je vais à mon
avis c'est la télé qui vous en remercie
chacun essaie de vous réveiller je sais
que j'aime mieux me réveillais j'écoute
ce qu'il dit est intéressant dans ces
écoutes et j'ai pas de raison
d'intervenir j'ai écouté ben moi j'ai de
la forêt alémanique arnaud il est
d'ailleurs chez vous chez madame et
messieurs vous êtes des réunions et nous
vous en remercions vous êtes des
millions à écouter ce que dit monsieur
lagerfeld
alors vous travaillez vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure au travail pour chanel on
en parlera voterez pour fendi fin dit il
faut le dire pour les français c'est ses
cinq soeurs italiennes qui ont une
maison de fourrure absolument la plus
grande maison de fourrure compte aussi
du monde d'esat les choses de près on
fait l empire lemond je viens vous avez
bonne conscience karl lagerfeld parce
que vous avez déclaré le vison est une
bête très méchante qui déteste l'homme
comme ça finalement
quand on fait les manteaux oui vous
savez l'histoire avec la fourrure c'est
bien gentil tous ses discours mais je
vais les mêmes choses saba dans ce cas
là il faut pas porter une cuillère il
faut pas manger de viande ça va loin de
tout ça c'est pas il peut appeler se
dire cette cause aussi elle est raide
très mal défendu par deux choses tabarre
doc des horaces et des gens de la mode
et où déjà n'a plus envie de ne pas
faire de la fourrure de la peau qu'elles
soient pas contents
et puis deuxièmement aussi ces dames de
sonorisation qui paie le prix d'un c'est
pas parce qu'on jette une espèce
d'animal mort sur une assiette de mon
amie anna wintour des voix aux
américains que nous on doit renoncer à
faire la fourrure parce que les 10
millions ça fait pas partie des choses
qui m'impressionne voilà nos donc cédé
très très mauvaise cause il ya plus de
vaches queues de vison
oui d'accord mais ça me dit qu'il faut
les supprimer plus vite les le bastiais
n'a plus non dans mes caleçons à
traduire
je pense que ces cachets fait rien
c'est qu'elle regarde pas la même chance
d'accrocher le fork en interview sur
arte 1
vous avez dit qu'après tout la fourrure
c'est jamais qu'une housse à viande
bessanais qu'est ce que c'est d'autre
oui ça donne vachement envie de porter
de la fourrure un marché de la viande je
veux dire c'est pareil avec la wii jenna
vient non mais arrêtez les gens qui
marchent l'avion j'aime pas ça j'aime le
jem le poisson ouais je compte que vous
êtes contre le port de la fourrure est
sûre ça me paraît évident ben non ça
sert et des jeux d'arcade est tellement
pour les emblèmes pas tellement mais
pour les femmes tout ça c'est joli mais
là vous parlez d'esthétisme mais bon
c'est le billet vert une hypocrisie
totale alors de quoi à part ça vous
dérange pas les chaussures non mais tu
te dis pas que les chaussures beiges et
regardez bien ces deux fois c'est le cas
depuis petula clark
c'est du plaisir d'accord mais tu la
quittes ses boutons de nacre a été
arraché à à une huître et c'est très
cruel aussi faire il ya un film de
truffaut je crois avec françoise dorléac
et gens d'essayer
il sonde à orly en plus d'orly et il est
pour 12 et à un moment donné françoise
dorléac je trouvais génial
dix agents design tu vois il ya une
femme qui porte une reporter imprimé
panthère et ça c'est les femmes qui
aiment l'amour là oui c'est ainsi alors
karl lagerfeld vous dessinez un peu
maintenant je vais acheter un manteau de
fourrure
ça tient pas car la guerre la dent dure
1 parce que vous vous avez dit pas
inquiet mais défendre je partage
jeudi passé à attendre mais ce que ce
sont les vôtres lagarce évident mais
vous vous êtes un peu comme pierre
cardin sur vous dessinez plein de choses
plein d'objets plein de trucs et que je
me sente que lui en faisant le garde à
vous dites c'est devenu un marchand de
soupe
il a maximois pas oui d'accord donc oui
d'accord oui par n'y aura pas n'y aura
pas à manger chez lagerfeld galerie
djamen non non non vous dit en parlant
de chanel vous dites chanel n'aurait pas
aimé je l'aurais pas apprécié je pense
que je peux vous dire il l'a elle
l'aurait d'été est alors en parlant de
chloé qui est une maison pour laquelle
vous avez longtemps dessiné chloé vient
d'engager la fille du beatles paul
mccartney qui s'appelle stella mccartney
et vous avez déclaré moi je voyais je
trouve ça drôle pour passer quand même
pas très gentils vous dites il voulait
un nom ils l'ont eue mais dans la
musique
elle voulait que je raconte l'histoire
de cette faute oui le sodi stx a dénoncé
le journaliste qui a écrit ça et essayer
besoin de téléphone tout n'est rien il
n'a pas pu me joindre il a écrit ça il
me dit tu comprends c'est comme ça que
tu parles je voulais me oui
ah oui d'accord tous les dires je n'ai
pas dit mais tu parles comme ça chaque
année
quant à la mauvaise réputation c'est
vrai maintenant je les lui j'ai cru vous
l'aviez dit est ce que ça aurait été
prêt à le dire vous savez on peut pas
dire qu'elles sont perdre tellement
inconnue elle est qu'il est quand même
un peu plus connue qu'elle donc oui vous
pensez que cela fait croire depuis
oui alors quand j'ai vu le film de
robert altman s'appelait prêt-à-porter
vous étiez il y avait quelqu'un qui
parlait de vous comprenez que c'était
vous étiez pas cité et on disait que
vous étiez un voleur me sens copieurs
pas au sens de deux volets et vous avez
essayé de faire interdire le film en
france on a quand même gagné du coupé la
séquence et dans certains pays je suis
arrivé on m'a demandé est arrivé à
permettre un bip sur le mot voleur mais
oui mais ça a retardé la sortie après
les films dépasser d'actualité oui et en
rien qu'en france c'est sorti comme ça
quand même non je me rappelle pas si
jamais ici en allemagne j'étais arrivé
il ya des pays où il est arrivé à le
faire interdire complètement le film
c'est à dire il a été très très de
retarder le temps que le jugement soit
accepter appel et compagnie si si il y
avait aucune raison mais c'est surtout
parce que c'était un mauvais film ça
aurait été un très bon film et
d'allemand à fait prêt d'être un très
beau film mais celui-là était pas bon
donc c'était vraiment dur comme scrupule
à le faire interdire le kaiser de la
mode un peu abattu laissé sur le cul
faut que tu enlève ton caleçon et h
missions qui sont y très sympathique les
seules personnes qui trouve grâce à vos
yeux karl lagerfeld c'est le style gotha
quoi vous raffolez des particules et
d'être honnête ou non il ya plein
d'autres gens aussi j'espère en tout cas
je crois vous avez déclaré par exemple
que vous êtes très aimé que monaco je
vais aller le contraire les appels
j'habite amman ap
personne n'est parfait dit marie laforêt
j'étais très ami avec les monaco vous
avez déclaré cheikh hassan à journaux
vous avez déclaré le prince albert est
très spirituel et oui tout achat peut
tout à fait ça vous confirmez a tant vu
passer une soirée vraiment se marrer on
appelle à leur santé écrivent lui l'a
gardé une image très élevé d'arts et
médias
mais dans le privé il est très
divertissant très amusant et fait des
limitations extra limites qu'ils ont
sérieusement ça je voudrais pas moi je
fais un tour du mois je peux vous dire
qu'il est lui a coûté faudrait que je me
réveille parce que je me suis rendormi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
heureusement qu'ils attachent à et
marissa mayer tu es un petit côté ouvre
à savoir écouter on en parle encore
générale d'achat faisait quelque chose à
dire au sujet d' albert parce que c'est
vrai qu'on vous a présenté comme sa mère
chez oh ça le truc sa future épouse on
peut le dire un moment et une couverture
de paris match vous étiez la princesse
qui étaient promises albert c'est un ami
c'est quelqu'un que j'estime beaucoup et
j'estime toute la famille de monaco et
enfin on vient de dire la même chose que
quelqu'un libre c'est un garçon à
monsieur monseigneur qui êtes vous de
vous pensez aussi qu'il est extrêmement
spirituellement spirituelle très
intelligent vous de vous confirmer sa
vérifie ma théorie comme quoi les
français après avoir tué luis elles ont
choisi les grimaldi viennent comme
famille de substitution
oui vous êtes vous connaissez pas de
monaco vous non mais moi je suis
quelqu'un de normal donc il ya pas de
problème avec des chaussures en cuir
chez désolé mais ça c'est pas normal
alors donc car les gars ici
non je passe à monaco karl lagarfeld
vous êtes barons des bars ou est ce
n'est pas les titres ne m'emballe pas de
particules mais bien des titres en suède
quand même phrase c'est autre chose les
particules croyez moi alors est-ce que
non la femme est ce qu est ce que c'est
vrai car comme tous les matins je passe
c'est vrai ce que tous les matins pour
égaliser la couleur et vous protéger de
la pollution vous fait un shampoing sec
oui c'est vrai et je la laisse oui mais
la rouge cas d'être mère le catogan
c'est parce que vous avez joué qui frise
oui oui je suis las de la météo c'est
marrant pour le suédois d'avoir les
cheveux qui frise la gangue d'origine
suédoise aurait mélangé en cours de
route que vous aimez vous d'accord avec
cette approche non merci pas compris
dans tous les sens et je les brosse que
le soin car la pollution s'est dit donc
c'est ça on a fait ça pendant des
siècles shampoing sec puis dès qu on la
voit beaucoup pour ça devient blanc
comme ça rien on mettra des chamois 6
est déjà pressé du shampoing sec et le
ici le match comme ça et je les brosse
le soir voilà il matin que je voudrais
que j'ai monsieur je suis gris foncé au
lieu des cheveux blancs c'est notamment
vrai blanc est assez réussi là c'est
vrai que tous les jours depuis ont
d'ailleurs le col de votre chien on voit
bien votre chemise qui était move comme
le reste avant le col est devenu blanc
aussi voyez mais cette folle ou pas
quand je le rappelle car c'est vrai que
depuis l'âge de 11 ans vous mettez des
costume sombre et une cravate
oui depuis l'âge de 11 ans river seul
fait que vous pouvez l'enlever
maintenant oui mais finalement
celui-ci troupes avaient tué pour avoir
envie de les enlever mais j'ai envie
d'enlever le chronogramme sait pas ce
qu'on va faire avec mais je dis toi la
question plus sérieuse là vous dites je
n'ai aucun but je les ai tous dépassés
oui je suis pas très ambitieux c'est
fini maintenant vous non non je fais
pour faire et je pense que c'est la
chose la plus honnête et la plus
agréable de faire des choses parce qu'on
a envie de le faire voilà pour tous les
pères et mères pour arriver à faire avec
ses parents vous êtes un peu quand même
vous ce qui a commencé avec moi finira
avec moi par louise anne me concerne
personnellement oui une phrase terrible
de vos six et dans la forme que dans le
fond je m'en sors pas mal vous doutez
bien j'en viens à me faire mieux mais
enfin dans le fond je écoutons jean
pierre dans le fond je m'en sors pas mal
à mon âge je pourrais être pathétique
oui c'est vrai j'accueille karl
lagerfeld
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'arles bonsoir merci d'être là
on commence comme pour tout le monde
avec des mails vous il y en a un que
j'ai particulièrement retenu karl
lagerfeld est il vrai que vous vous
soyez fait greffer votre tête sur le
corps d'un homme masse au lieu d'avoir
fait un régime
j'aime l'idée mais malheureusement ce
n'est pas encore au point
karl lagerfeld 11 42 kg de moins en 13
mois
tout le monde en parle il ya déjà un an
que j'ai arrêté oui ah oui c'est pas
repris et j'ai pas repris un grand oui
je mangeais pas en même temps si si si
si si c'est contraire à ce qu'on pense
avant alors pourquoi ce régime commence
régime
c'est ce que vous expliquez dans un
livre qui s'appelle le meilleur des
régimes
[Musique]
alors un livre que vous avez écrit karl
lagerfeld avec le docteur jean-claude
outré et qui est publié aux éditions
robert laffont voilà karl lagarfeld donc
un moment vous étiez à 102 kilos pour 1
mètre 80 ça mais je n'ai pas beaucoup
ouais aujourd'hui vous êtes à 60 kg et
général c'est des gens qui ont eu
quelques kilos de trop qui trouve que
c'est un peu je sais pas pour vous mais
moi le général c'est ça j'ai aucune
personne ne m'a jamais dit que je les
trouve dans tous les cas j'espère que ça
sera pas comme twitter parce que lui il
a fait un régime il a fait un bouquin et
après il a pris 50 qui lorsque c'était
le meilleur des régimes à c'était pas le
sait vraiment si les ventes
oui d'accord enfin moi il ya déjà un an
que j'ai arrêté d'ailleurs j'ai pas
voulu faire les livres avant si on fait
un livre et on redevient une boule c'est
pas très honnête non moi je me prouver
que j'ai une année où je suis resté
comme ça
ouais à l'année prochaine vous vous
lâchez alors c'est bon c'est pas ça la
méthode est bonne je laissais aller mais
c'est sûr qu'à cannes se lâchera en fait
quand la meute de reviendra dès des
vêtements en classe je viens fashion
victim voilà parce qu'en fait c'est pour
porter les costumes dior homme cintrée
d'hedi slimane qu'il a fait ce régime
saleh c'est la seule raison et annaba
dont il y en a pas d'autre c'est que
carla dès que j'avais une raison
sérieuse c'est loupé il a dit je vais
être un centre pour porter des vêtements
cintres et si la distance formidable
toujours car la gare c'est mieux de dire
une chose comme ça et de faire des trucs
un peu superficiel dans les discours que
d'arriver pour un sujet pareil raisons
profondes qui gagnent à l'éthique soit
là alors vous avez perdu à peu près en
poids l'équivalent d'un jeune top model
quoi vous allez pouvoir porter des
tailleurs chanel maintenant je ne suis
pas encore sûr que de vouloir changer de
sexe a alors les liquides vous avez
perdu on a l'impression que c'est jean
paul gaultier qui les a pris non il a
soumis au régime jeu le but de landreau
lille avait
il était très en forme ça je suis là
pour défendre mes confrères il a
beaucoup maigri est devenue la baie de
nha karen mc queen tout le monde s'est
mis avec sandra mcwhinnie fait le régime
aussi ami il a bien maigri ça lui va
très bien
1 ainsi une secte maintenant vous savez
pour arriver à quelque chose il faut le
traiter comme une secte presque oui mais
il n'y a pas de suicide collectif
oui alors vous êtes sens de la formule
zi le régime est le seul jeu où l'on
gagne quand on perd à montréal une des
amendes de logique non le roi des
slogans vous êtes soit pour votre look
est ce que vous êtes soir pour le look
des autres comme ça est ce qu'en voyant
quelqu'un ne juge jamais ce que les
autres portent donc je peux faire de la
mode mais je ne suis pas injuste de mode
dédié les horaires vous êtes mal habillé
je ne porte pas du skal par exemple
vivant vous vous trouvez qu'elle est
bien ses chemises non franchement car
franchement on la connaît mais ma
demande où elle vient donc je sais à ce
prix là ça m'est en effet la concurrence
il a pas mal pour les lions
c'est à dire qu'elle était bleu moi vous
me changeriez mon look là où c'est un
classique maintenant lab est un peu là
je n'avais pas besoin d'autant dépôt le
fait est un peu trop de métrage n'a pas
besoin d'autant oui ça c'est l'argent
s'achète du tissu à l'aso m est ce que
par exemple arlette laguiller vous
pensez qu'elle a un bon look ou est-ce
que vous la roucarié j'ai pas vu des
plis et donc ça va bien je la trouve
mieux en brune camblong qui vous auriez
envie de bernadette chirac par exemple
une amie à vous vous trouvez qu'elle est
bien lookée que bernadette chirac et de
la polique les gens de la politique
s'ils sont trop bien bloqué on se moque
d'elle kizomba bien que bien habillé on
se moque du aussi c'est très difficile
la mode ou le vêtement et la politique
ni c'est bien c'est pas bien si c'est
pas bien c'est pas bien non plus alors
je préfère m'abstenir
parce que franchement il n'y a rien à
faire c'est un c'est un truc sans espoir
c'est votre amie bernadette chirac
moi je la trouve fantastique comme fin
mai elle nous a donné un bon coup de
main quand à l'époque vous avez des
problèmes les impôts car est vraiment
voyez une lettre cela demande des
avocats qu'elle a donnée aux gens c'est
aux avocats non mais tout à fait mais je
dis pas qu'on doive aux avocats vous ont
demandé de signer une lettre destinée à
bernadette chirac pour lui demander
d'intervenir dans votre problème fiscal
c'est une pratique apparemment très
courant en france je la plénière mois la
limite raccroché au nez
je trouve un peu ingrate elle oublie un
peu ses amis comme a appelé à voter pour
son mari oui moi je suis un pauvre
étrangers c'est la même chose car doit
pas faire la soirée là dessus mais vos
impôts ont quand même été ramenées de 80
millions lamanda 46 millions est-ce que
c'était justifié
alors là on va pas sortir le dossier oui
vous avez tout si ça durait six à bure
et 16 ans c'est qu'il y avait des
problèmes c'était pas si simple que ça
oui c'est vrai mais le fait que
certaines personnes n'y a pas que carl b
entendez mais que certaines personnes
puissent négocier comme ça avec le
percepteur en disant ballon faire ce
thème un pas forcément raison je veux
dire il ya des données dans ces
histoires c'est pas si simple que ça je
pense que si ces choses-là dure si
longtemps c'est que c'est pas tout blanc
ou tout noir mais en même temps à ce
niveau là vaut mieux récupérer un petit
peu que tout perdre non si les étrangers
je vais te dire parce qu'ils ont peur
que les étrangers à vivre à l'étranger
donc ils disent il vaut mieux qu'ils me
donnent 46 millions à nous en france que
rien du tout monaco en allemagne par
exemple simple que ça c'est à dire là
dessus il ya un truc sur lequel il n'y a
pas eu de problème finalement c'est
l'histoire de la cassette méry parce
qu'on a dit à un moment une plaisanterie
voilà non mais voilà les balles
présentés
rien de plus qu on a vu son visage
c'est l'avocat fiscal de karl k qui a
donné la cassette méry à dominique
strauss kahn
quelle époque était ministre des
finances et on a pensé comme il était
l'avocat de carl qui donnait cette
cassette à strauss kahn qui pouvait
l'aider évidemment qui donnait cette
voie là pour avoir un rabais et en fait
ça jamais c'est même pas c'était un
monsieur qui s'occupe d'une partie de la
sphère j'en avais plein d'autres
d'avocats donc c'était beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et beaucoup plus simple
en même temps oui on va revenir au
régime ce sera plus qu'à c'est mieux oui
c'est un autre genre de régime ça régime
fiscal en 83 en rentrant chez chanel
vous aviez déjà fait un régime non oui
mais c'était plus modestes s'étaient
inscrits 15 kg humains comme ça - et si
c'est exact et non pas du tout pour la
mode actuelle et pour le look que je
voulais à l'époque c'était suffisant
saint louis dakar
alors après je pris par indifférence pas
pour négligence parce que j'ai trouvé
que pétain les milliards de raisons
et tout d'un coup j'en avais ras le bol
et quand j'ai perdu les premiers 20
kilos je pouvais remettre de ce que
j'avais à 20 ans et la jeune fille mais
qui c'est qui celui là j'ai pas envie de
le revoir cela alors 20 ans ah oui mais
non non ça je suis contre le voyage dans
mon propre passé
en tous les cas je suis là il marcha je
crois que je vais suivre les conseils du
bouquin parce que moi c'est pas autant
que vous que j'ai à perdre à bien sûr
mais un petit parce que là il reste très
peu vide on faisait pas fait de
liposuccion - non sursis car regardez
moi dans les yeux les bas dans les yeux
qui vous regardez c'est ailleurs qu'il
faut regarder
oui on aime ça marche pas du tout
d'abord ça marche pas pour des gens de
plus de 50 ans 1
donc il faut être beaucoup plus jeune et
non vous savez si vous perdez le poids
très lentement n'a pas besoin de faire
soi même et puis vous avez comme souvent
les hommes les bras et les jambes ça
reste maigre et ça se met là c'est plus
difficile
moi c'est unis comme un anorak un peu
partout j'ai enlevé la doudoune et en
dessous il y avait le squelette avant
parce que la vie liposuccion on a dit
aussi que vous étiez malade vous savez
ça quand même mais les gens dès qu'ils
ont fait à 3 kg en est malade les gens
adorent la maladie de s'échauffer
une belle à naucelle dit le sexe des
sujets chocs mais j'adore j'adore tout
ce qui est créé à canon mais non des
fois je fais un peu attention quoi pas
pour des raisons de santé je pense que
il ya un an je ne veux pas trop grossir
voilà c'est tout quoi ça va vous êtes en
forme
ouais très bien ça va vous demander
votre âge arlette oui j'ai 62 ans
vous êtes passé mais moins 70 ans et
demi ça conserve la révolution et oui je
pense que les idées ça bien sûr ça
permet de voir la vie avec plus de
petits bisous et des régions
donc j'ai toujours été en fait très très
très maigre on m'appelait soeur de lotus
au fil de fer comme total et notre ami
patrick quand j'étais petit mais après
oui vers vers 30 ans j'ai commencé à
prendre l'eau douce attention toujours
mais bon j'ai eu quand même une
quand on est fait d'une certaine manière
enfin je fais pour être mince au départ
j'avais toujours très beau parce que
c'est que des masques dans comme des
beaux seins ben oui on s'en occupe
ce qui est fascinant car dans votre
histoire c'est qu'en général à votre âge
pas 64 ans on se dit bon ma bastaque one
a à faire c'est là où vous êtes
extraordinaire c'est à dire merci non
mais vraiment parce que c'est vrai bon
c'est l'âge de la retraite 64 ans aux
yeux après tout vu mon métier c'est plus
normal
oui parquet est-ce que alors votre
régime donc qui apparemment marc géria
rien à dire oui ça est ce que est ce que
c'est facile à faire quand on n'a pas de
cuisinier si bien sûr je connais des
gens qui le font
non parce que c'est relativement simple
si vous aimez les livres c'est
relativement simple
je connais plein de gens qui pourraient
peut-être en avoir mais qu'ils le font
humain parce qu'ils aiment faire la
cuisine
apparemment très faisable alors vous ce
qui est bien si vous avez votre votre
frigo de voyages lâcher sa fortune à un
frigo de voyage mais pour remporter ses
yaourts
donc il a un frigo l'eau tiède c'est pas
très bon oui c'est franchement
dégueulasse davari le frigo de voyage il
à la manette pour les compléments
alimentaires fit mal être mais si je
passe à deux ans 13 organise ce week end
au ghana alors la mallette pour les
compléments alimentaires et un étui à
carte de visite pour l'épauler les
vitamines bientôt nous les faut bien le
dire quelque chose
irrité cette chose les mis là dedans ça
doit être sympa de voyager avec vos jeux
non san encombre pas là c'est pas vous
qui pensez pas qu'on sait rien ne vaut
mieux pas un danger public grâce et
d'accidents comme ça alors le grand truc
c'est pas toucher la nourriture elle
vous dit ça vous dit que en fait quand
vous allez chez les gens vous allez
manger je ne mange que chez moi et aux
heures régulières
en général je ne touche pas d'autres
nourritures way la discipline alors car
donc pas toucher la nourriture quand on
va chez des gens prendre soin de manger
avant et puis alors si on mange une
bouchée de plus que ce qui est autorisé
on la bastille dans l'art crash
vous recracher la nourriture au début
sinon vous l'aimez frustré s'est trouvé
la frustration tête quel pays au monde
donc vous faites ça mais vous faites là
chez vous avant témoins est ce que vous
vous faites vomir
non j'ai pas besoin de david à dax avait
pas de marche arrière alors vraiment
fait jamais vaut mieux non je peux pas
je sais pas ça marche pas c'est dalida
quand elle faisait des régimes elle se
faisait voler bas si je dois me comparer
à dalida à c'est un peu vous avez
déclaré karl que pour faire ce régime
vous avez été obligé de devenir auto
fasciste oui mais il vaut mieux être
autres fascistes avec soi même et avec
les autres
oui la chirurgie esthétique vous y
pensez je ne suis absolument pas contre
si la fête je le dirai mais il se trouve
que je n'ai pas encore fait mais je ne
suis pas contre mais on va quand vous
avez maigri votre peau a été elle devait
être un petit peu flasque même le geste
un peu comme ça non non non non non
si vous maigrissez lentement c'est pas
comme ça et puis ma peau si vous aimez
c'était un cuir bien entendu vous êtes
trop tendu sur trop de choses mais comme
je n'ai jamais fumé de ma vie donc pas
un vieux jambon fumé jamais bu d'alcool
et jamais pris de drogue et vous savez
ça vaut conserve quand même il n'est
rien
je suis d'un ancien prix d'ouverture là
vous êtes vachement bien conservé
non alors c'est vrai que vous êtes
devenu très sage karl lagarfeld futur
était très fort mais l'attendait pas
toujours acquis très sage moi je vous ai
connu par exemple à l'époque de la main
bleue en 70 ans d'accord mais vous vous
avez ce qui est dur et chiliens femme
vue au bordel et sentiers de plus vous y
voir mais vu la sexy mais voilà me dites
pas que vous êtes toujours été très sage
parce qu'on est en fait pas parce qu'au
moment de voir dans un endroit public
j'ai quand même survécu mieux que la
plupart des gens oui à la main bleue
lundi les trois heures c'est un endroit
jones au lendemain de la fameuse fête le
maire à evian il a été à dire qu'à
montreuil avait une boîte de black qui
s'appelle la main bleue et qu'un garage
au troisième sous-sol d'un parking
garage mais qu'elle organisait une fête
qui a été absolument monumental aussi
belle que ses effets plus tard au palace
et le lendemain le maire
d'arrondissement était une chose que
vous avez c'est de fait personne n'a
rien vu de mon emploi parce que c'était
dans le noir ça s'appelait le moratois
noir mais avec les flashs des
photographes il ya des scènes qui sont
sortis du noir que les gens ne voyaient
pas et effectivement s'est passé des
choses que en soixante quinze ou non si
c'est alice est on n'avait pas
franchement l'habitude n'avais rien à
prouver
ah oui seulement l'ambiance big room
chez eux mêmes très courageuse même pas
dire et pourtant je ne m'aime pas dire
ce que j'ai vu non mais tu vas le dire
quand même non
merveilleuse il regardait bouchez vous
les oreilles pourquoi mais moi je n'ai
vu que le lendemain il ya eu c'est vrai
ce soir là c'est la première fois de ma
vie que j'ai vu des séances de fist
fucking mais moi je n'ai même pas vu moi
je les bleus voulaient justement en
parlant de mode karl lagerfeld j'ai un
mail de catherine de tours qui dit la
vraie fourrure revient à la mode
qu'en pensez vous que pensez-vous du
combat de brigitte bardot karl lagerfeld
tout le monde se souvient des photos des
bardeaux en panthère et en visant donc
je ne sais pas ce que je dois penser
pourquoi la fourrure c'est quand même le
vêtement le plus ancien de l'humanité
avant de pouvoir tisser on savait déjà
c'est la fausse fourrure c'est bien
gentil le c'est quand même pas la même
chose et encore et encore du cuir et on
mange de la viande c'est à peu près le
même dit oui franchement donc je savais
déclaré le vison est une bête très
méchante qui déteste l'homme et bien
c'est bon c'est vrai ça donne bonne
conscience
je ne suis pas à la recherche des bonnes
consciences mais vous avez suivi les
quelques recherches de faire technique
des animaux carnivores des herbivores
un gouffre en les récoltes mais c'est
pas grave mais mais pourquoi un tigre
qu'il faut protéger de bouffer 30
animaux par jour mais nous qui nous
contentant d'un petit kilo et encore
mais franchement si on le voit comme ça
c'est très débile mais au fait c'est
discours est quand même souvent très
hypocrite
oui ça vous choque vous que les femmes
s'habillent de fourrure moi je trouve
qu'il ya des matières synthétiques
superbe très légère qu'on lave en
machine son côté lutte ouvrière
oui
qui vous savez karl que inès est venu
ici inès de la fressange sais pas mais
je suis ravi de l'apprendre elle a été
très gentille avec vous milito cesse
donc ça commençait un peu à se dégrader
avec karl lagarfeld les relations à ce
moment là non c'est à dire qu'au bout
d'un moment il ya eu cette histoire de
marianne dans les maires de france ont
décidé que je pouvais être marianne et
donc ça va énerver comme ça non ça oui
il a dit tu devrais refusé vie comme ça
la tête comme ça dans tous les cas il
s'est bien vengé
il vous a fait défiler avec une seule
robe brodée de fleurs de lys ans il a
voulu me faire défiler avec une seule
robe brodée de fleurs de lis moi j'ai
dit non je trouve pas ça drôle et que je
le ferai pas l'indicé phare pour rien ne
sera rien et voilà
oui
c'est quoi ça veut dire quoi c'est en
éviction de chez chanel a retrouvé des
images s'était fait jeter ya lagerfeld
derrière justement alors le problème
c'est ça c'est xavier rencontrer luigi
et c'est aussi ça du land jaloux car non
vous étiez moins à lui ne s'était pas
vraiment fiancée car la garçonne non
plus d'accord papa il est très possessif
il est très possessif in health quand
même non je tiens après cela chouette
chouette nolwenn ont peut-être qu'il a
dû sentir un peu abandonné il a dû ciel
va moins s'intéresser au truc est tous
là peut-être fait une petite parano il a
dû penser bon même plus que ça puisque
les fold amoureuse et tout peut-être que
là maintenant elle va pas s'intéresser
vraiment à ce qu'elle fait à la main
comme se sentir trahis
moi je comprends maintenant j'ai appris
après tant d'années que les jambes et
réagissent souvent par leurs peurs ou
l'espagne à l'époque
bah ouais tu être un non c'est vrai
qu'ils vont bien devoir bien sûr se voit
il savait pas du tout à quel point je
tenais lui c'est sûr ce soir la bête là
du coup il a perdu 57 kg c'était l'image
de la version du document d'enfants
s'étaient livrés cet instant suspendu
tout ça hein je préférerais peut-être un
boyfriend précédent à 8 j mais j'ai rien
contre lui 6 1
donc tout ça c'est beaucoup moins dans
le camp dans l'huile livre le peu que
j'ai lu ça avait l'air presque d'une
romance doit beaucoup plus terre à terre
et beaucoup moins renommés
maintenant j'aime bien il est ce là la
vraie
ans du départ d'inès de chez chanel bien
vous l'avez donné où ça dans lunettes
noires magnéto serge tu disais c'est la
française idéal puis le jour elle été
choisie comme la française idéal c'est à
dire pour incarner marianne ce qui fait
qu'il est acceptable
là tu t'énerves et aline ont annoncé
bourgeois c'était une guerre et danny
bourgeois ni vulgaire c'était au fait
ouais pour dire gentiment à quelqu'un
puisqu'après madame atik j'étais jaloux
des années déjà pour le dire c'était
plus interdire ça que de dire n'importe
quoi je pense que de temps pour être
mannequin qui s'est passé là aussi d'un
travail pour mettre tout ce qu'elle a
dit elle oui c'était pas monolithique
mais parole et elle co victime se débat
comme ça
[Musique]